Okay,wehaveanupdate,sortofonthisissueoftestingforthebeerbugaswearereferringtoitbe
orCorona,youguysgetit.
Thebackstoryhasbeen,weneedtostarttestingandweneedtostarttestingnotonlysymptomatic,
people,butifwereallywannahandlethisproperly,fromapublichealthperspective,weneedtodo
withSouthKorea.Didwhichisyouidentifyanareawhereyouknowyouhaveacertainnumberof
casesandthenyoutestahugenumberofpeople,evenpeoplewhoareasymptomatic.Youtestthem
forantibodiestoseewhatisthelikelynumberofrealcases.Thisgetsussomemoreaccuratedeath
rate.Thiscommunicatestopeople,eveniftheyhavenoreasontothinkthattheymightbe
contagious,thattheyactuallyaredespitenotexperiencingsymptoms.Soweneedtotesttoget
updatednumbersweneedtotesttopreventspread,weneedtotestasamatterofpublichealth,the
whooffertotesttotheUnitedStates,theTrumpadministrationsaidNotheCDCisgoingto
developourowntestthatfailed.SonowweareslowlyIguess,gettingmoreandmoretestsfrom
theWHO,butthequestionishowmanypeoplehavebeentested?
TheTrumpsaidit'sabeautifultestthatanybodycanget.Turnsoutthatdoctorsay,No,wecan'tget
thetest.I'mhavingahardtimegettingthetest...Say,somanydoctors.
So,SecretaryofHealthandHumanServicesAlexAzar,goesonCNNandisasked.Sohowmany
testshavebeendone,what'sgoingonwiththetests?
Trumpsaidit'sabeautifultest,that'swidelyavailable.Alexisarehasnoidea,andhestartsquoting
theA­E­I,theAmericanEnterpriseInstitute,hegolookatthis.
HowmanyAmericanshavebeentestedatthispoint?
Wedon'tknowexactlyhowmany,becauseofhundredsofthousandsofourtestshavegoneoutto
privatelabsandhospitals,thatcurrentlydonotreportintoCDC,we'reworkingwiththeCDCand
thosepartnerstogetanITreportingsystemupandrunning,hopefullythisweek,wherewewould
beabletogetthatdatatokeeptrackofhowmanywe'retesting,wethinkwe'vegotthroughputat
themoment,probably10­000aday,oritcouldbegettingtestedbytheendoftheweek,20000a
day,accordingtoastudybyAEIthatIheardabout.We'vegotnow21milliontestsavailableat11
millionhaveshipped.
03/11/20 Page3of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­11­commercialfree
Soagain,testsavailablemeansverylittle.Ifdoctorsdon'thavethem,theymighthave10000test,
sittingsomewheretheymighthaveamilliontestsittingsomewhere,itdoesn'treallymatterifthe
testsaren'tavailable.WhyistheSecretaryofHealthandHumanServiceswhoiscoordinatingthis
readingreportsfromaconservativethink­tank,theAmericanEnterpriseInstituteassumingthat's
whohe'sreferringto,abouthowmanypeoplemightbeabletotest?
You'resupposedtoknow,isanyoneelseconcernedthattheSecretaryofHealthandHuman
Serviceswhenaskedaboutanumber,heshouldknowindependentlysays...Well,Ireadfromthe
AEIthatbyweekandwemightbeabletotest10or20000peopleaday.Theofficialnumberof
peopletestedasofyesterdayis8500.Okay,that's26people.
Hermillion­inthepopulationthatisinsanelylow.Bahrainistestingnearly5000peoplepermillion.
We'retesting26SouthKoreaistestinga4­100permillion,we'retesting26inHongKong,they're
testingmorethan2000peoplepermillionwearetesting26,thosecountriesaregettingthisunder
control,wearenot,andwehavetested26peoplepermillionfront.
PartofthisisTrumpthinksthatalargernumberofcaseswillmakehimlookbad.Now,ofcourse,
itwillexposethatwe,whenhesaidWe'reunlikelytohavemanycaseswelikelyhavesomewhere
theofficialnumbersovera1000,therealnumberisprobablybetweenthreeand6,000basedon
estimates.I'mlookingatTrumpthinksmorecaseswillmakethemlookbad,it'llmakethemlook
likealiar,butweknowhe'saliar.
Heshouldunderstandthatifyougetmorecasesthatlowersthedeathrate.
OneofthethingsTrumpsaidearlyonisIthinkthedeathrateisgonnabemuchlowerthan
34%Thatmaywellbethecase.
34seemshigh,andthisisgoodnews.TheSouthKoreandeathrateis07%,theUSdeathratessofar
is03%anditwouldbelowerifweknewthefullnumberofcasesbecauseclearlyit'smorethan
1000cases.
There'safewotherpositivethings,maybethatIwannamentiongoingonwithallofthis.
Italyfinallyhadadaywithfewernewcasesthanthedaybefore,Italyhasbeenoutofcontrolwith
this,andthey'reareallyproblematicshapeintermsofdeath.Fullcountrylockdown,it'sverybad
inItaly,butItalyhadleadinguptoyesterday,eightstraightdaysofmorecaseseachdaytheyfinally
hadareductioninthenumberofnewcasesyesterday.
Ifthatcontinuestogodown,that'sagoodsign.
We'llknowinaboutaweekor10days.
Numbertwo,Chinaisrapidlyclearing100to1500activecasesperday.So,Chinahasthishuge
numberofinfectionstobeginwith.Butforthelastweekorso,Chinaeachdayhasonly20to100
newcases,butaround1000to1500peoplearerecovering.Ifthattrendcontinues,youcanseehow
mathematicallythatgetsridofitwithinChina.Ifitdoesn'tcomebackin,orifthingsdon'tbecome
03/11/20 Page4of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­11­commercialfree
moreproblematic.So,I'mhopefulbecauseformethisisnotpolitical,thisisjustpeopleIwant
peopletobehealthyandtoliveintobeokay.Thismaybeaninflectionpointthatwearegettingto
wherewemaybegoinginagooddirection,that'soptimistic.
Wealsomightnotwillknowmore,probablywithinthenextthreeorfourdays.Letmeknowwhere
youthinkthisisgoing.I'monTwitteratdepartment.We'lltakeabreakandthereisjustsomuchto
discussit.